nous sommes avec anthony cahier
secrétaire national du syndicat cgt
police bonjour merci c'était trop
directeur avec nous sur rt france 3 mise
en examen pour homicide involontaire
pour la famille de cédric joue via la
qualification pénale est trop légère
quel est votre sentiment aujourd'hui il
existe et c'est bien celle ci aurait
fallu avoir dès le départ puisque il y à
une personne décédée est donc dans ce
cadre aulas devrait y avoir entre et
l'automaticité de la saisine âge de
sectionner l'ouverture d'une information
expliquez vous alors que ça ne l'est pas
été le cas dès le départ de l'enquète
ajouté seule explication
je ne sais pas une explication qui
regardent les services de police mais
c'est l'explication qui regardent le
parquet puisque c'est le lui seul qui
est habilité sur la poursuite de
l'inflation et donc c'est à lui de
saisir le juge d'instruction est ce que
vous vous avez le sentiment qu'il y as
peut-être aujourd'hui un aspect
politique dans cette décision alors et
au moment où les forces de l'ordre sont
pointés du doigt depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines
effectivement voilà une affaire
d'homicide
vingt deux fois sur 30 l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire pour celle-ci
effectivement il n'avait pas eu pendant
que j'ai en moi
les faits vous connaissez tous
aujourd'hui on a effectivement sentiment
qu'il ya un rattrapage de cette affaire
judiciaire
peut-être très concrètement les
conséquences de sa mise en examen sur
les relations entre la police et la
population était concrètement c'est que
au moins c'est un peu le sentiment
objectivement de l'état essaie de
rattraper les mois ou où il est désert
judiciaire sur cette affaire et
peut-être de montée de l'état pour
reconnaître ou non la culpabilité des
policiers engagés sur ce contre minsk
est largement pour vous qui êtes
policier le rappel secrétaire national
du syndicat cgt police qu'elle regardait
ce que vous portez sur le comportement
de ces quatre policiers impliqués dans
la mort d' cette action vient ajouter
100 sans présumer l'issue de cette cette
affaire compliquée on n'a pas les
éléments vus d'aussi des regards des
faits n'a pu entendre et voir dans les
différents types de presse en tout cas
il y avait quelque chose de grand
dysfonctionnement sur le procédé sur la
façon de faire la façon de s'exprimer
vis-à-vis des citoyens
l'accroissement de mener un contrôle
d'identité favorable on part sur une
affaire qui au départ n'est qu'une
simple contravention et de voir ça
sa tenue ce sont des actes menés par une
minorité de policiers qui font beaucoup
de mal à l'ensemble de la profession
minorité par une majorité au vu de
l'écho du retentissement médiatique que
ça c'est évident que que ça crée une
fracture entre les citoyens et sa police
et ses clients moi ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui pour remédier à notamment ce
sentiment d'impunité aujourd'hui de la
part de la population à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre défenseur des droits a
souligné il ya quelques jours l'urgence
de faire évoluer à la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre est ce que vous vous
partagez aussi ce constat cette
nécessité
je partage totalement exister de revoir
objectivement du match alors dans son
ensemble je vais essayer impérieuse à
mon sens de revenir sur une réelle
police de proximité n'est pas une police
ou une psp on devient appelé le ministre
les antennes des chiens parce que ce
n'est qu'un coup de com souvent dû nous
n'avons plus les adjectifs pour
effectivement mener à bien une ré une
police de proximité c'est bien ça la
difficulté c'est que aujourd'hui le
citoyen quand il a affaire en la police
et entre 10000 n'a affaire qu'à une
police précise c'est à dire que quand
arrivent les faits ont eu lieu c'est que
ce soit la victime
où que ce soit en potencier le mis en
cause qui serait à l'origine une
infraction
aujourd'hui la police et une intervient
que pour sanctionner un dernier pourrait
venir et c'est bien ça le aujourd'hui ce
qui est montré du doigt
merci beaucoup entraînés à la gaillette
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire national du
syndicat cgt connaissent